now we're going to take a look at an old
mexican tradition that's getting a new
life in this country the escaramusa is
an all-female synchronized team
equestrian competition look at that it's
become more popular in the u.s thanks to
young women embracing their ancestors
customs including a woman who had an
awakening she says when she visited her
grandparents in mexico lilia luciano
shows us how she became the american
queen of the mexican rodeo radio rodeo
on a rural ranch outside seattle 21 year
old paola pimienta and her family put in
long hours on horses practicing a sport
that goes back centuries and that has
been in her family for generations how
many saddles are
i haven't even counted them myself
before there were cowboys and their
rodeos there were mexican charros and
their chateria and what's actually
really interesting is that the american
cowboy originated from the chattel the
american cowboy originated from
yep what
is mexico's national sport only men
competed until women joined in about 70
years ago now the women ride in their
own event in teams of eight performing
choreographed tricks with their horses
they're called escaramusas and they
still ride side saddle and with a male
saddle you sit normally with both of
your legs down
the arena where they perform is called
the lienso which also means canvas in
spanish and that makes sense when you
see the escaramosas galloping in
it's a site that mesmerized paola as a
young girl of mexican descent who was
born and raised in washington state
seeing them in action changed everything
she felt about her heritage when i was
younger i felt like i was trying to
assimilate into american culture i but
at the same time i felt like it wasn't
my place i didn't have a lot of friends
i started getting fearful of speaking
spanish
my parents would come with me to
different places and i was almost even
kind of embarrassed of
of being mexican in a sense
until she started spending her summers
in mexico visiting her dad's family
there
everyone from her grandparents to her
young cousins practice the sport i would
see them and i would be like wow i wish
i could do that back home because if i
want to do that i have to come to mexico
but what really drove me was when i had
a cousin of mine tell me you're never
going to be in escaramusa because you're
gringa
the sport was only introduced
competitively in the u.s in 1991 so for
paola there were few teams to perform
with and for me it was kind of that
moment that it clicked
like i have all odds stacked against me
gereria was a tradition paola's father
juan mario left behind when he was a
young man and crossed the border to work
and eventually start a family in the u.s
what was it like for you when paola said
she wanted to continue the family's
tradition here i was really happy
inside
that she want to follow their dreams and
i was really happy that she chose a
charity
so happy he bought then 11 year old
paola her own horse barbie and found her
a team to compete with in buckley
washington just about 2 400 miles away
from mexico
for the next decade paola and barbie
would train almost daily at the family's
ranch and travel throughout the u.s and
mexico competing and winning
when we practice we wake up sometimes at
four in the morning you'll have boot
camp sessions so you'll do three days of
writing two to three times a day your
objective is perfection and to win and
that takes so much work and so much
sacrifice
the sport takes endurance discipline
and deep pockets the rules are strict
especially when it comes to the team's
attire we actually have to ride in
earrings that are handmade so they have
to be artisan made in mexico oh my god
the rules are unbelievable yeah there's
so many rules yeah from the silver
threads to the sombrero to the patriotic
embroidery all tells a story about
mexico's history and heritage
last month paula triumphantly returned
to mexico representing the u.s as the
american nationalist caramusa ambassador
a four-year title she won for her
writing skills
what would you tell little girls who are
growing up in the states with hispanic
heritage we are such a beautiful
community to be able to speak two
languages and to be able to carry that
with us we go back home and everyone's
so proud to be mexican to bring that
here and have that diminish
it could burn out forever it's a little
fire that could burn out forever paula
has fueled that fire inspiring the next
generation of escaramusas to chase their
dreams
i just get chills because i know the
struggle that it's taken for me and my
family to get to that point it's the
best feeling in the world for cbs
mornings lilia luciano buckley
washington
wow bravo
people always say i always learn
something when i watch this show i think
that's a great example of that i had no
idea it's a beautiful piece i think a
lot of parents right now are getting
questions from kids at home can i have a
pony for christmas thank you lilia